it's election season again we've already
had multiple debates so the big day must
be just around the corner right wrong
Election Day 2016 is November 8 2016
that's 366 days away let's put that
number in perspective the 2015 NFL
season from kick off super bowl is a
hundred and fifty days that means almost
two and a half seasons can fill the
space before the next election any bones
broken during those seasons take on
average six to twelve weeks to heal
which means you could consecutively
break and heal for different bones
before next November okay so let's talk
gestation periods a human pregnancy
lasts about two hundred and eighty days
a baby can see today would be nearly
three months old on Election Day even
llamas who take their sweet time with a
gestation period of up to 360 days if
they have started now they could still
pump on out before the vote fruit flies
have a lifespan about 30 days that's
around 12 generations between now and
Election Day and human time that'd be
almost 300 years all right forget the
earth let's go to space the Apollo 11
mission went to the moon and back in
eight days 366 days would accommodate 45
trips forget the moon NASA's rover
Curiosity made it to Mars in 252 days
that's more than a hundred days less
than will take for us to know the next
leader of the free world last month
Canada finished its longest federal
election campaign since 1872 so how long
was it 78 days what so chill out America
we've got time
Wow
[Music]